[Music]
I was 184 but I was so much fall in love
with the wrestling
WWE's Hussein cosgro Ali vasiri AKA The
Iron Sheik
has died he was 81 years old
his death was announced in a statement
posted to his social media Pages
Wednesday reading in part it is with
great sadness that we share the news of
passing of the Iron Sheik but we also
take solace in knowing that he departed
this world peacefully leaving behind a
legacy that will endure for generations
to come
the Iron Sheik helped put WWE on the map
in the 1980s playing a villain fans
loved to hate something he opened up
about in a documentary for a e
nice call
but not enough
I can make a good living I said well I'm
tired I don't want to work quicker
anymore I want to be about to go
have a new champion
his wrestling career spanned nearly four
decades notably going toe-to-toe with
Rivals like Hulk Hogan it was very easy
to hate
I could be so different but all that
also made him a fan favorite he won the
WWF world heavyweight championship in
1983 and was inducted into WWE's
Wrestling Hall of Fame in 2005. the holy
family was a great feeling and people
was the luck if they look they were so
excited very happy to see me
touch yourself
leaving behind an incredible Legacy
introducing the Challenger the iron
the iron cheeks survived by his two
daughters and five grandchildren
[Music]